he went from rapper to slapper now his
career's in the
crapper
see that and as diversity consultants
make big bucks the final product still
sucks
so will smith has resigned from the
academy of motion picture arts and
sciences effective immediately
in a statement will says
[Laughter]
he says
i would have respected that
but he says his actions were shocking
painful and inexcusable like when he
puts his son in his movies
shocking painful and inexcusable i use
the same three words to describe kill
me's last book
and it still was the best review he got
will says he hopes by resigning the
academy can quote get back to the
incredible work it does to support
creativity and artistry in film well
news flash magellan that ship has sailed
the only creativity they show is coming
up with new ways to produce woke garbage
witness the growing trend of biased
consultants firms hired by students
studios to comb over their scripts and
flag anything considered problematic and
it's not just scripts but every level of
production now gets filtered through a
woke lens of intersectionality and as
long as there's money to be made in bias
consulting there will never be an end to
the cries of bias or racism but it's
like my aunt bertha used to say
rub my feet greg it's the only thing
that brings me joy in this
i get world yeah yeah
what are you gonna say johnny
i'm not gonna ask you to rub my feet
i mean you can
i mean i'll never know neither neither
of us
neither of us will get anything out of
it give me a you could give me a nub hug
oh my god if you want to know what that
is see me after uh you're terrible
hollywood's gone nuts uh
but uh isn't this kind of about money
now isn't it like when consultants get
inside a place it's all about just
getting paid
this is a lot about running from
yourself right now like they are in a
place where these are the people who
told us that masculinity was toxic that
uh told us that violence is never the
answer sometimes it is uh hey you know
sorry but it's true like these are the
people that have virtue signaled us out
of our own culture right acting like
normal people for a minute and i don't
mean that to excuse will smith or
anything but this is what normal people
do like i'm telling you sitting at the
house or you're sitting on the front
porch in the neighborhood and somebody
yells you know something bad about your
about your girl you go punch them in the
face like it may not be right but it's
you understand it i can understand it
and so i've come full circle on this and
i've made it all the way around to the
point that i'm mostly mad that people
care yeah no there's uh i think i get
always quote arm and white on this it is
better on the will smith fiasco to be
ambivalent
like like uh do not like take any sides
just look that everybody's dirty tammy
everybody's got a dirty hands in the
whole thing it's a collision between you
know awoke celebrity culture and hip-hop
credibility just head first you know he
had he had to like he had to say it he
had to slap him it was wrong they like
jerry springer yeah and geraldo yes
never know what's going to happen yeah i
know what's going to happen with her but
you know nobody nobody really knows what
really how the academy started the film
industry here started pretty much with
people from burlesque from nor from new
york
and they thought they really needed to
try to show the american people through
the news rules that would happen that
they're serious and that they can dress
up and that they can be trusted right
and look what is this a hundred years
later and we're back to smacking each
other in the face on the stage what what
for me was shocking was i agree with you
that sometimes you go maybe you need to
slap somebody who offends your wife if
that's what you do
did he not remember he was at the
academy awards right did they know
that's how selfish well this is but it
but and he was laughing
she got upset apparently from the and
she looked at him and was clearly upset
about it uh and that's when he then
decided to go and do that extraordinary
thing
but it seemed to be such a break from
reality
that is why americans didn't get it
because you know
you grow up loving films and you you
want to have this be a break from
reality and suddenly it's not on top of
that
nobody knows who won the oscars except
him yeah there's no discussion about the
movies or anything else and there might
have been some good stuff i fair i
wouldn't have known i never do
like even with that bump
abysmal ratings uh-huh and so what is
the worst what would have been the worst
if it was
does he have to give his trophy back or
does that just mean i don't know i think
he's inconsequential he needs to go away
for a year they're still investigating
him it's also hilarious like he's such a
like a control freak and he's so full of
self-importance that he quits the
academy he can't wait for their judgment
he's like i don't care i don't need you
yeah and you're like [ __ ] they just
invited you to you to a party and you
cried
it happened it does happen
usually i go into the broom closet and
not enough people are talking about what
a fantastic job chris rock did
just for like taking that slap and
moving on with the show because i'm
telling you i'd still be on the ground
yeah i would still be there i oh i got
whiplash i'm hurt i'm going to sue i'd
be talking to lawyers
[Laughter]
cat you know what i noticed that was
interesting do you find it weird that
there were so many movies up for the
oscars it's almost like hollywood really
didn't participate in the lockdown did
you notice that it was like it's like
wait what if we did an awards show
they didn't participate in lockdown
because they filmed their movies in
georgia and our governor didn't have a
lockdown ah there you go march 16th 2020
that went away for us that's interesting
because the pandemic they didn't have if
you're like a rich famous celebrity then
it doesn't apply to you right uh tell me
about it that's why yeah you get it
uh and that's also why will smith had
the exact same apology as every other
rich famous celebrity it was exactly the
same it was all of them he said i am so
sorry there's no excuse i accept every
consequences and i will do the work and
it was just so weird to see this apology
over a physical assault be almost
exactly like chris harrison's apology
when he resigned from the bachelor over
something he said right that's so true
you should print those out you can spill
those coming up he's glad to be rid of
trump no matter what you have to pay at
the pump hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else